coming up on 609 on your Finally Friday
what's driving you crazy well a viewer
wants to know what's taken so long to
finish a freeway off-ramp in the
Northwest Valley
Russ writes about the westbound Northern
215 Beltway exit to Hualapai seems
there's no sense of urgency adding a
second right turn lane traffic is
congested with red light Runners and
intersection blockers why is this taking
so long well Russ the Clark County
Public Works Department tells me there's
a lot more going on there than finishing
those turn Lanes saying the work
includes lane widening signal upgrades
and relocations adding that there are
long lead times on getting traffic
signal parts
in fact the county says they're actually
working with the city of Las Vegas to
see if they can help with those traffic
signals and finally the county says hey
that 215 Hualapai interchange it's now
part of a bigger project in the area so
it's work on the Beltway from Craig Road
all the way up and around over to Grand
Montecito next to the Centennial Bowl so
Russ sorry I can't give you a better
timeline but I hope this helps thank you
for writing buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone you can join
the driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com